hello we're glad you've joined us for
this slide webinar acclamation of
training animals for standard handling
restraint and laboratory techniques I am
Christina Mahalo collaborates and I'll
be moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
libraries the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by libraries to
learn more visit lab roots comm let's
get started you can pose questions to
the speaker during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them in the Q&A box which
will open once you click on the green
Q&A button located at the lower left of
the presentation window questions will
be answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button down at the top right
of the presentation window or report
your problem by clicking on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
screen this is an educational webinar
thus offers free continuing education
credits after the webinar is over please
click on the C e button located in the
bottom left hand corner of your webpage
and follow the process for obtaining
your credits it is my pleasure to now
present today's speaker senior training
specialist Kaylee Bennett University of
Michigan training core Kaylee Bennett
began working in laboratory animal
medicine in 2008 but her passion for
animals steadily grew from a young age
Kaylee graduated from Eastern Michigan
University
with the Bachelors of Science in
behavioral psychology short shortly
after graduation she joined the
University of Michigan as a limit
laboratory animal technician quickly
obtaining her registered laboratory
animal technologists searched
certification Kaylee forms the animal
enrichment committee creating various
programs in sessile socialization and
enrichment for rodents and large animals
as a senior animal technician she
transitioned into a position with the
biomedical engineering department ever
seeing a population of rhesus macaques
felines and rabbits Kaylee participates
in a less locally and nationally serving
on the Michigan a last Executive Council
she completed various scientific posters
presentations authored a book and
co-authored multiple manuscripts she
recently accepted an opportunity to
share her knowledge as a training
specialist Kelly implemented a
compassion fatigue peer support group
for and volunteers for lab animal for
the lab animal community through public
outreach
she was named national a last 2016
technician of the year specialist
Bennett will now begin her presentation
Kaylee the floor is yours
[Music]
you so much for such a great
introduction and thank you everyone for
tuning in I really hope that you guys
can take a lot from this and from our
program before we begin I would like to
say that everything in this presentation
is per the guide for the care and use of
laboratory animals has been approved by
our AIA cook at the University of
Michigan and is on protocols just all
right hold on one second so I would
first like to start by introducing the
training core population at the
University of Michigan we have eight
dedicated training specialists with a
variety
backgrounds animal care including
surgery anesthesia experience husbandry
experience were all very diverse
backgrounds with rodents and large
animals have a fairly large animal count
for our training core we have 15 rats
and about 15 rest having any given point
in time you can see in the picture we
have our rats housed in groups of four
and rat condos we have approximately 140
boxes of mice and those can have
anywhere from two to five mice in them
and our population does fluctuate
slightly during the year we have eight
rabbits and eight guinea pigs we do to
offer large species training but this is
on demand so we'll occasionally get
large species in for a short period of
time but with those we often like to use
the labs current animal population with
all that being said we will be expanding
our training course soon potentially
doubling the number of animals in the
next two years and adding more training
specialists as well so our large
population we are also looking at
expansion where we get our animals from
we do like to practice the 3 R's from
the ALS mainly the reduction of
laboratory animals we have two colonies
on campus the germ-free colony on our
breeding colony and most of the Train
where animals are surplus animals from
these colonies the Jim free colony
breeds animals in a germ-free setting
and it often have surplus animals in our
breeding colony ran by breeding measures
breed hard degree less strains and for
our labs community and when they have
excess animals we are often able to take
those as well that accounts for about
80% of our animal population when we
have the direct need that those colonies
cancel so we need a specific strain or
color of animal we will go through
vendor usually the Charles River vendor
but most of our animals are transfer
animals from surplus Commons with all of
those animals we have a wide variety of
topics that we cover in the training
cord
we cover all husbandry training so all
of our husbandry staff go through our
training port and this is to Train basic
animal care high handling equipment
maintenance and documentation and
record-keeping we do laboratory animal
handling for our lab staff so how to
handle our animals properly and
restrained for different techniques and
those techniques I have a small list
here this is by no means a conclusive
list of the techniques that we train
more common ones we tray injections are
gavage blood collection surgery and
anesthesia knee crafts the intersection
and basic animal training but pretty
much one of our mottos is if you need to
be trained on it we can train you or we
can find someone that can they have a
very large veterinary staff we have both
veterinarians and resident veterinarians
so we have a lot of knowledge pool that
we can program so the techniques that we
don't know we are learned from them and
they can help us out so we've never
really had a training request that we
couldn't fulfill but does this all mean
but we have a growing animal population
that's already quite large and we have a
heavy class load this is through
regulatory expectations that have been
increasing I would just knit more
classes for our labs because they need
more education we also have an increase
in specialized technique requests which
means we have more specialty classes and
specialized techniques can often require
more trainers and more animals as those
are a little harder to learn and we kind
of leave our animals during class as
we're learning these specialized our lab
members and so it's kind of contributes
to our growing population so with all of
this is this large population all of
these classes and all these specialized
techniques we found we had some concerns
to address in our training for namely we
really want to reduce the stress in our
training for animals some of them we're
a little difficult to handle maybe they
weren't used as often as other animals
that our population especially if they
first showed that they were a little
difficult because a lot of handlers that
we get in class are not as endless
and are already kind of concerned about
handling animals and when the animals
act a little fractious they tend to shy
off even more and therefore there is
potential for overuse for the animals
that are easier to handle and a little
easier to use in class this also leads
into varying student comfort level we
have a wide variety of lab staff at the
on campus at University of Michigan
probably had a lot of students that have
decades of experience and they're our
principal investigators refresher and we
have some people who've never even
handled an animal at all before let
alone a rodent species and maybe even
phobic about rodents so we have it runs
the gamut in our classes and we want to
make sure that our animals don't
experience any stress with these varying
comfort levels and all of this so we
came up with some solutions in the
training corps to help with this we have
an acclamation and positive
reinforcement program for our animals we
do environmental enrichment enhancement
for all of the animals that we house we
have practiced a few methods of
technique refinement for these handlers
from the labs to reduce stress on the
animals but also to reduce stress for
our lab numbers we're also currently
working on an enhanced database to
streamline our data management and make
sure that we cycle through our colony
effectively and use all of the animals
we have so well how do we start that's a
lot it's a long list of things that we
want to get we wanted to accomplish in
our training core and again with a
fairly large and diverse population so I
like to start this presentation with
some of the global methods that we do
for our animal population for all of the
species that we house and this is just a
little picture although that's what we
have in our lab space with various
training core animal toys that we can
give to our animals to kind of make the
experience more pleasant and more
enriching for them there's a lot of our
methods are universal for species where
we're kind of more popular programs is
really had a lot of success is our
acclamation program and this is just
handling acclamation for animals once
they're transferred to our colony in the
lab space that we give classes so the
used to the environment and used to the
handling sometimes they haven't been
handled much at all often times they're
very young before they're actually put
in class and potentially restraints so
there's less stress in class they've in
our room before and they've been handled
and they've and they know us as the
trainers and we also allow them to sit
in on classes and that just means when
they come into our meeting horn making
they kind of had sit in their cages next
to me while I give class before they're
actually in the class so they can get
used to the sights a lot of people
before they're actually participating in
that class and this gives us easier
animals to handle it's less stress on
the animal and it's also easier to
perform classes and techniques on these
animals and one of my favorite points of
this is we often strive to push our lab
really a create their animals to
handling into the lab environment before
they use them for research and by doing
this in our classes we model acclamation
for our research staff not only do you
say it benefits them we can see the
benefit for them and for the animals but
they can also see how much easier it is
to do their techniques and to handle
animals that are acclimated to handling
us so this is just kind of another way
to drive home that point that animal
welfare
equals better science and this is kind
of one of my cilia slides but in
Jurassic Park blockbuster movie in the
90s all of the dinosaurs in the park are
female and the social house all of our
social species which is all of our
species then and we make sure all the
rats and rats are female but we also
don't want to but more importantly we do
this because rats and tend to be smaller
as they age pills and we want to keep
all of our social groups together for
these animals we don't want to have to
separate even into pairs from our rats
and we're able to keep her caged density
size is the same with these animals and
don't have to worry about them
outgrowing caging and have to find new
caging or potentially break up social
groups so we make sure that all the rats
and rabbits
our female in our training core to make
sure that we're keeping up with social
housing with the mice and the guinea
case this doesn't seem to be too much of
a concern we can keep our social groups
fairly well with both sexes and we also
offer extra in cage enrichment for all
the species at the University of
Michigan all animals have at least one
piece of enrichment and all of our
training core animals have at least two
pieces if not more in their cage and in
this picture we have two rats in the
standard shoe box style caging but they
have three in different enrichment
devices in their cage which makes a bear
an environment much more interactive and
allows them to display natural behaviors
that they normally wouldn't be able to
and I'll just kind of point out one rat
is in an opaque Hut like to buy though
is very reminiscent of a burrow that
they would normally be in there's a knob
lock that they can chew on there's also
inviting paper that mace is supposed to
nest in but their ads tended like to
burrow under it and kind of nesting this
demonstrates all enrichment types again
our lab members get to see all of these
enrichment types and they get to see the
animals interacting with them and
displaying natural behaviors that maybe
the labs haven't seen any animals
display before don't see the rat
burrowing if there's nothing to burrow
and you don't see them gnawing except on
their food if there's nothing anon so we
get to show them this is why in Richmond
is important and this is what your
animals naturally would like to do in
the wild so they can see the more
natural behaviors with all of this we
also evaluate enrichment items for our
animal enrichment committee we have a
very robust animal enrichment committee
there's many technicians technicians
veterinarians on the staff of the entity
and there's a lot of ideas from all of
those staff members there's a lot of
people with a lot of different ideas and
they have to be evaluated to be
effective for the animals so first thing
they have to go through obviously past
safety and health concerns through our
veterinary staff but then at the
training core we get to test drive those
after they've deemed safe see if they're
effective is enrichment and I have one
example down there one of our
technicians came up with the idea that
they really enjoy cotton swabs
they seemed like knowing and there was a
gnostic and those patton swabs and then
there's cotton on the tips much like
cotton square that you would give a
mouse or a rat to make a nest out of
like nestling took us awhile actually to
find cotton swabs that were didn't have
bleach in them we finally found some
organic cotton swabs passed through that
so there was no chemicals in them and
then it came to us to see if the animals
would actually use them I thought it was
a great idea and we gave it to both mice
and rats and I will say both species
loved them they come up they take them
right to their nest and then they
destroy them in about five minutes and
you can see that they were even in the
cage so we found that they liked them
and that it was enriching but it wasn't
really effective as an in cage
enrichment item because they disappeared
within five minutes and you couldn't
really use that as a you know as a very
long-term enrichment item so it's on the
database is safe and effective but not
really realistic in our setting and I
actually kept the box that they gave me
and I give them this treat store
[Music]
demonstrates another way that i betray
niko really tries to be on the forefront
and cutting-edge of innovative
enrichment and animal welfare issues so
we can demonstrate these for our labs
and so that we can be on the forefront
for our animals
we also offer high value treats to all
of our species we make sure all the
treats obviously are species-appropriate
though we do have a lot of overlap with
our species they get treats after every
training event and usually beforehand
when they first come entertaining space
we and I have a few pictures a one or
popular ones are the bioserve foraging
mixes we can just sprinkle that in Roman
bedding and they can forage for it as
well we have the Mardi Gras foraging mix
pictured here and the veggie medley
those are our two most common for the
rabbits and guinea pigs we also offer
them fresh fruits vegetables herbs just
different types of fresh foods that they
can deconstruct and be really enriching
for them and I did add a little caveat
here about nut allergies as I said we
have a very large lat and diverse lab
staff that come in for training and it
was brought to my attention that the
Mardi Gras floor G mix had
a bit of peanuts in it and I know that
there's a lot of allergies out there two
different types of allergy is very
common and it can be very times deadly
and that we don't screen people for
allergies before they come to class and
so I we didn't make the decision to keep
that specific 4G mix for just when it's
the training core with the animals or
people that we know and we use the fruit
and veggie medley when there's a class
and I like to highlight this keep in
mind that the enrichment the food that
you give the animals interact well with
the animals and with the users and
handlers of the animals that are also in
their environment they have a very large
interactive environment in the lab space
and have to keep all of that in mind we
also use human interaction for our
animals and this is a lot like
acclimation handling right like it even
used to it being handled but I like to
highlight this especially with rats
we do have a contact through the
breeding colony there's a lab that is
continuously breeding wrapped they only
need the male's so we get the females
from their litters and we get them quite
young and you can see that adorable
little mewling rat right there and when
we get them we handle them frequently
mainly for our handling acclamation
program but also because they're
adorable and you can see in the other
picture there's a you know an adult rat
being very interested in active while
being handled and we've noticed that the
rats tend to view human interaction as
enriching they like climate coming out
of their boxes and we put when we open
their cage they climb right out and onto
our arms and seems very enriching to
them to have that relationship with us
as tolerating it through acclamation so
we do count that as a type of enrichment
we don't count it but it does seem to be
very enriching they they do that little
purring chittering thing the rats do and
are happy when we swish their heads they
kind of burrow right into our arms and
stay with us during class so we find
that that end for us as well I mean
they're adorable so that's another thing
to be offering them and kind of
segwaying from that we do have some
species specific things Ferrari and also
species are different but that we do for
the training Porter really makes them
more comfortable and these pictures may
look a little silly
we have one of our trainers
Wanda came up with a great idea speaking
of the different varying comfort levels
of our students we've had a few students
when they come to class and they see I
have a live rat won't enter the room
they have very phobic of rats rats you
know they're larger they have that long
pink tail we have all our bye no rats
and they have red eyes and there we have
people that wanted to enter the room and
she came up with a great idea we've got
a lot of really colorful kind of
goofy-looking socks and we cut four
holes for their legs and then we only
really had to put down them twice before
they would start to just kind of run in
girl they seemed like being in these
sweater socks and because they lie right
down and they're very calming them and
it hides their tail and it kind of makes
them look you know it stuffed animal
right they look a little silly but every
time we've had somebody who's feel
because rats to the point of not
entering in the classroom we've done
this and they've always come in after
that and start handling their racks
after a while because they're not a
scary looking at a lot of people say
handling we just slowly take that
sweater off and show them it's the same
animal that you earth rate of and then
we can go ahead with the class it's
we've had a really good success with
that we don't have to do often but when
we do we find series besides that when
we train our classes we have surgical
tables that the animals are on the lab
members can demonstrate the different
techniques and restraints and we found
with the rat specifically they tended to
not like being on those tables right
they were close she's switching around
and seemed like they were looking for
footing so we just took some wash cloths
and laid him on the table and we also
noticed the tables kind of seemed a
little cold so we thought maybe the
washcloths had bothered from that cold
and give them something to grip onto we
put them on the wash class and they
automatically calm down and just kind of
sit there and let us handle them
appropriately so we do that in all our
classes now just as something extra for
very animals to keep them even more calm
and to reduce their stress levels we
also have another idea for novice
handlers we call it our shoe cover
restraints and as simply me take
a standard shoe cover that's made like
the poorest cotton like material not
plastic once we have the rat enter the
shoe cover going towards the toe and the
way you would put your health you were
using as an actual shoe cover and we
find that you can really restrain them
easily this way people get intimidated
by rats or larger than mice they're
worried about getting bitten they're
worried about being able to manipulate
their hands properly over such a large
animal so this really helps by palming
the rats now again they seem to really
like being in the shooting here in this
picture and it pops on down it lets the
handler have some more control of
keeping those animals restrained you can
see us rat is being restrained for a
potential subcutaneous injection other I
could go and all the way and you can
pull out just one leg for potentially
intramuscular injection or you could
turn the rat over quite easily for inter
peritoneal injection so some of our more
those are some of our more basic
techniques that we train and it really
helps out with restraining the rat and
and again the rat seems to really like
it also for our rats we've just recently
within the past six months or so started
using rat condos instead of the standard
shoebox LKG
in the standard asset allocation because
been about two adult female rats quite
comfortably but we wanted to try to give
them a larger social group and to give
them a more dynamic environment rats
prefer a dynamic environment also
Allentown Meadows these great condo
cages for the University of Michigan and
we found you're trying about the
training core you can see there's more
floor space you can fit more key
enrichment so there's a Knobloch there's
I are drying the spots off camera low
bait there's you have to see there is a
platform that they can get on and
there's an access port and they can kind
of jump up on that platform and you can
see in that second picture they all
really like being on the platform
they're very interactive with each other
on it
and we get to see and show labs again
behaviors are animals they can jump
navigate an environment they can
manipulate an environment that that has
something to fill eight and we have a
larger social group these animals are
really quite social we haven't had any
aggression so far in these cages again
we do have females that were introduced
young but it's been a really good
success in a really good addition to our
training course so far moving on to our
rabbits I haven't really spoken much
about our rabbits but we do have again
eight long turn rabbit long term rabbit
colony they're female and they are pair
housed and we have our standard
Allentown caging for this they we just
removed the middle panel for two cages
and give them access they do tend to
kind of hang out in their own cages
sometimes you can see in that picture
though their house they're in their own
cages and so in the training court we
give our animals people exercise now
this is initially today obviously
promote natural gait some movements
allow them to go Hopsin but and also to
reduce their energy levels a little bit
during class so they're not so difficult
to handle for our lab staff especially
ones that haven't handled rabbits before
these you know these can be pretty large
rabbits but we also notice that it
increased their social interaction
because they had more again dynamic
environment to interact with by you can
see we first put them in and their
finger on and then they together and
start eating the treats and playing with
the different toys and really
interacting more in that larger setting
besides that weekly exercise for our
training for Abbot's we also do offer
them we call rabbits lay time in the
training core lab we bring them to our
training course space and the cat
carriers they're used to coming in their
classes but we did the same type and
they had in their housing room and we
put it in the space where we would hold
class at them we offer a variety of
enrichment for them and trainer
interaction so they can interact with us
and bond with us outside of a classroom
setting but they can be in that
classroom when there's not all of the
class s members and different
manipulations they're just having fun
they're just being
give an enrichment and we get so bond
with them as well which we've really
noticed increases the ease of handling
them and we also really enjoy it and
this is again this is one of our
trainers lawanda
she was petting and brushing them
offering them treats and making just
generally easier to handle and work with
and we've noticed the rabbits really do
tend to I mean we open up their carrier
and they kind of come right out into
dark space now before they were
apprehensive for our mice we offer we
always offer at least uh two pieces of
enrichment like our other species but
for the mice we make sure it's two
pieces of nesting or shelter enrichment
and I put these pictures on for a reason
we gave them a nest or a cotton Square
to make into like a fluffy nest we also
gave them a shelter and you can see they
tore up the cotton square but if you
were to score that nest it's actually a
fairly poor nests court they tore it up
but the otherwise kind of trampled on it
and didn't really use it to make a nest
you could say I also give them some
foraging food they were sniffing at but
when I'm not wasn't interacting with
them they were inside their huts and
this shows that we gave them choice
between the nesting material or the hot
garden shelter and they chose the
shelter as the preferred shelter just
their shelter enrichments they tore up
the other one but they didn't really use
it properly this shows that you can give
the animals choice and it makes their
environment less stressful right because
they got to use the preferred method but
it also lets us interpret and modify our
enrichment so now actually I rodents
after these pictures were taken they
gave our nice creamy paper or we call
enviro dry and that's so they can make a
mold woven nest like they would in the
wild and oh we can give them some
environments but just a mess Allah alone
without another piece of material didn't
seem to work for our colony and we got
to see that and have them tell us that
so we don't have to you yes and figure
out what they want an enrichment if we
give them choice they have more control
and again I like to show this to the lab
staff so they can see that they the
animals do interact with their
environment depending on what we give
them to interactive
also for my sphere technique assignment
this is our wires on the table idea that
we had that doesn't have ventilation
through a port though this is an
upside-down wire it would be in a box
that was holding a water bottle and I
flipped it upside down and it's at a
great angle to teach me to teach a stuff
first rate for our knife and it's a
degree angle to teach this for novice
handlers it also gives the animals the
mice something to grip onto instead of
that smooth surface so they grip right
onto that wire and kind of stay pretty
still hold on to them and these are for
them as well we also when we teach this
stuff we have some lab members concerned
that they might be pressing down too
hard on the mice and by doing this with
the wires it allows the mouse the legs
especially to go somewhere when you're
pressing down so we are able to see give
the handler some peace of mind that you
can push a little harder on these
animals you're not some gift so it's
less stressful for the animals because
it is a surface with some give if a
handler is being a little you're just
learning the ropes of restraints so and
we notice a lot of them do take us up on
using his wires confusing for a guinea
pigs
we offer social housing in a drawer
system and this is because any pigs
don't tend to use any pigs don't tend to
use levels like rats do so we give them
a lot of floor space and this allows us
to put more Ian Richmond in their caging
that they would actually use so the
drawers are pushed into Iraq gives them
some darkness in the back that they can
retreat to and also allows us to put
hots then you can see there's loose hay
and there's also toys that they can
manipulate the throttle on occasion
there are shower
but this allows us to house them in
larger groups it also allows us to give
them the toys more proper for them to
use as especially for guinea pigs and
rabbits but we've noticed that guinea
pigs especially tend to like fresh herbs
so we started what we call our
administrative herb garden so to our
administrative staff that don't normally
have an interaction with our species our
animals we are able to if they have the
overhead lighting like you see in this
picture we give them kits to grow the
herbs that we have approved for our
animals so they get the pot in the dirt
and the different seeds and then they
grow these herbs and we've no system
forces a gap that the administrative
staff has they can actually impact
animal welfare and the animals really
love it it's all factory enrichment
because it's also really great
especially for the staff and it really
allows us to you know come bridge that
gap between our staff that don't have
and animals really seem to like it but
we also do mean or like species we name
our rats the only reason we don't name
is because it's easier to keep track of
them this is an example this is me and
CeCe I know we have some kind of cutesy
looking designs near their names are
those who actually do serve a purpose as
well mia has a red tail a mark on her
tail and Cece has a blue mark we do have
albino rats so that makes it easier to
tell them apart and it's easier to talk
about Mia having potentially an issue
like Mia having alopecia and so at three
four five and the bottom I did include a
quote from SUNY Buckmaster but she is
the past
elast president as well she's very
passionate and vocal speaker for public
outreach for the animal research
community and she is not whoever papers
animals they're named
and therefore seen as individuals may be
tended more carefully that makes them
less stressed and better for study and I
tend to agree we are more attached and
guess we just won't get more attached to
animals that have names we remember them
more and I think that makes them less
stressed and better for study and again
I keep saying this guy loves did not
left for labs you don't have to name
your animals but that is an option as an
option so that's a lot of information
it's a lot of animals it's a lot of
trainers and there's a lot of different
classes that we're training how do we
keep track of all of it well our current
system we use is a hard copy or paper
system our animals are only kept on our
protocol for one year we don't want to
use geriatric animals during classes if
it's potentially stressful but we have
no soon animals are used more than
others we have a rule we mark on their
tails with a different color marker but
it's an easier mo work with who knows
that they tend to be used more or if
they're added more apps location on the
housing rack we try as much as we can
how we move from a foot board to putting
her use logs in a binder to be able to
flip back easier and see what animals
use last but it is very difficult
especially if you're short on time so we
meet in one of our administrative staff
mr. Ludwig I've been working on a
database and this is a demo of one of
the pages for a kid that age would have
for a animal county management database
now we'll be getting touch para where
the iPads or tablets house this nice we
can take into our housing rooms you can
see we have cage IDs species our
building they are in their facility when
they arrived what's their weight and age
cage primary color and we notice this is
very important so my lab staff they
practice till the blood collection and
later colored animals it's easy to see
the tail vein but if they're working
with dirty animals like the furrows as
well and then we have this
in the corner if the animal has to have
a week break it's not active but if it
is active active is lit up green is one
upon this mock cage because at the
University of Michigan we use green
that's the acetates on caged cards to
delineate where an animal is being
treated for issue so we want to know
when our animals are being treated for
medical issues because not to keep those
in our colony too long so we can use
them for an acute procedure or look into
them further we can also see when they
retired after that year mark and when
they're euthanized so we can keep their
files on board but we don't have to have
them in our active status and here's
another example of what it would look
like if the cage was active but a month
from their retirement date so we can
start to plan our classes with our
retiring animals and plan our when we
get transfers of new animals and we have
a leaving our colony so this is ongoing
and it should be up and running within a
few weeks so we're very excited for this
and everything this will help out a lot
using our colony effectively animals
will be listed on our database based on
when they were used last so it'll be a
lot easier to manage and manipulate our
colony I'm after retirement
we do offer in-house adoptions for our
training core animals I do like to put a
note here this does exclude transgenic
so if we get an animal from the Green
County for example however otherwise we
do try to adopt out our animals mostly
rat enough that we have adapted out mice
if you think we'll be adopting them we
do hold a last training class for
veterinary residents and this is just a
standard physical exam that has the
standard clinical techniques injections
spay and neutering all the answers
spayed and neutered I have a couple
examples here that's my old rat Simon
when we had male rats on a training core
he reach to teach kids by animal
research last year so she has two guinea
pigs from our program the variants love
when we have guinea pigs because they're
anesthesia so they can allow
and that's my dog through our hearts
dogs that are large animals that we got
for a short amount of time and then I
adopted him out and now he's a lump that
lays on my stairs
but I really think it's important that
we adopt these animals out so this would
be good ambassadors for animal research
asked a lot when I walk my dog about
where I got him from and I can see these
animals are happy and to be able to be
adopted out and again we can do public
outreach on etcetera so this we do only
do in-house adoptions right now but I
really think it's a great access to
asset to our program so the results of
all of these changes that we made for
our program the trainer's are more
invested in the animal population we're
excited to see them we interact with
them besides being in class so we have a
lot more investment our trainees good to
see optimal care they get to see all of
this great innovation and enrichment and
training that we can have for the
animals so they can know that there's a
different way our animals are animals
temperament has improved they're easier
to handle in class and they in generally
are interacting with their environments
more at least it seems and only to us
our animals are easier to identify they
have names and worries it's more easy to
communicate about them between all of
our diverse training staff and we're
kind of spread across campus so it's
easier to give out information on the
animals when they have names like them
better care is better science and our
new regulations do require consistent
training with our labs so we see them
more and we see them more frequently of
course it's a press every staff out
there I can't say that enough we are the
first people that anyone seen when they
enter a laboratory animal husbandry lab
staff if you're going to interact with
animals the first people animals you see
are the training corps we have a duty to
the animals to give that high value of
care so they have that baseline of
optimal care for animals they see the
best and that's what they expect them
they're on out and I think it's very
important that we start people's careers
that way our animals can handle
variety of techniques again our
specialty classes have been increasing
and it had a lot of success while people
are learning these specialty techniques
that require a lot of my new handling
ability with calmer animals and
therefore their more advanced techniques
can go through easier and that our
classes can go quicker and more
investment is a happier staff I love
these pictures that's new there at I
really love the rats that's my favorite
program so I'm constantly that's the
longest she really likes the rabbits and
she was it's fun to talk about them when
you've interacted with them it's fun to
share stories and come in and look
excited to see both your co-workers and
to you know train in animal research but
also to see the animals and have that
bond and that impact I would like to
acknowledge a few of our teams the
University of Michigan unit for
laboratory animal medicine that's the
unit I am working under and they're
great with as long as their veterinary
approved and not really you know have a
forefront of laboratory animal welfare
Neil I'm training core team which is my
team and it's a great team to work on
everybody's so passionate and so
invested and it's just really exciting
to see so much knowledge and experience
on one team the Elan breeding colony and
germ-free I didn't forget to write them
but animal transfers that we get so we
can practice that that reduction in
laboratory animal the University of
Michigan laboratory staff I mean we do
have great classes people really want to
learn and they really want to know how
to handle laboratory animals properly
and how to experience the best way
possible and I'm really encouraged by
seeing them and the Yulin animal
enrichment committee it's a great
committee they're very again very
passionate we have so many passionate
people at the University of Michigan
they just want to know as much as they
can and be very innovative in the field
so with that if there are any questions
this is Selma and Ruby these are my two
favorite rats interacting with their
environment look they're in the tube and
they're eating the forging wood I gave
them so is there any questions
I don't know what to do now Thank You
Callie for that really informative and
very interesting presentation a quick
reminder for our audience on how to
submit questions simply type them in the
Q&A box found by clicking on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of your
presentation window specialist Bennett's
will answer as many questions as time
permits so with that let's begin with
our first question
our first question asks curious to know
what caging type or manufacturer you use
for the rats yeah that's a great
question
oh there I am that's a great question
we actually it's Allentown Cajun and I
believe they're called rat condos but
that we do get our casing through
Allentown thank you our next question
asks for years I have experienced that
after teaching investigators a septic
rated surgery most of them in a
performing rodent surgery following pour
a septic technique what have you done or
do you do is it back on me okay there
yeah well actually that's a great that's
a great question and we have had that
experience as well sometimes we put all
this effort into training our lab staff
it seems to really impact them seems to
really absorb in and then we find out
later that they're not following all the
techniques we've displayed so we do
offer lab visits so we will come in and
if and you know it's the labs request
and we can watch them perform surgery
and make sure that they're doing it
properly
however if they
are in or there's some sort of citation
aseptic technique first things get
retraining and that's when we ourselves
known to them go back to their lives and
our next question asks what would be the
roadblocks to introducing rap condoms
into the general research in animal
population are there plans for this at
the University of Michigan oh well there
are some roadblocks and we have we do
have a list of pros and cons of these so
the animals really enjoy them and we can
house more animals together however
they're very cumbersome to handle I will
say it's a larger cage and it's heavier
and on that perch if they're on top of
approach can you take the cage top off
they do tend to kind of if if they want
they can adjust our so there are some
issues or roadblocks however at the
University of Michigan we don't allow
single housed animals for reasons of
size so we do use these rat condos if
animals especially the male rats its
large to be socially housed in the
standard caging have this is an option
and I know that we're kind of weighing
the benefits so far animal welfare is
kind of winning out over some of the
more rudimentary husbandry issues of
handling them so we are looking into
different ways to implement this but it
is it is slowly being introduced into
the main colony and I will say I think
the roadblocks can be fixed fairly
easily and I think it's worth it for the
animals because again it's a much more
dynamic environment for those rats so I
would definitely encourage doing a test
run like we did on just one rack of
animals that's a very standard
population like our training for animals
and listing out how it works and finding
solutions that way instead of just kind
of looking at the negative great and
questions keep great the questions keep
rolling in the next question asks are
new regulations requiring consistent
training U of M regs oh yes I should
have clarified as we're expanding as a
university well those are University of
Michigan regulations are starting to go
into maintenance training so once you
are trained on something looking into
different like yearly training refresher
courses and things like that and we're
also encouraging labs much more and
through email and lab visits to come to
us for training for specialized
techniques they're not required to have
training through us with specialized
techniques but we are pushing it and
we're also making surgery training a
requirement of surgeries on your
protocol for anyone who has surgery
experientially could do surgery yeah
that is increasing 2011 edition of the
guide for care and use of laboratory
animals came out in general there was a
lot of different things in that guide
and so slowly I
I guess it's been changing in our field
but recently at the University of
Michigan
thank you next question asks how long
does the acclimation period for rodents
last at your animal units well we don't
have any quite a set rule that they get
acclimation period for three weeks we do
try to kind of incorporate it as we're
working with our animals we have a large
enough colony with our training core
it's great that the University of
Michigan has a lot of to have a large
trained colony like that we can have
animals coming to the side for about a
month while we're getting them used to
handling and restraint we really
encourage the acclamation handling
operation in the training course so even
when they're starting used occasionally
just handling them maybe even after
class just handling them for a little
bit and then giving them a treat so they
can see that handling and it can offer a
variety of things they can be restrained
for it or they just be handle they can
cages so just kind of giving them a
variety of experiences so we try to give
them a few weeks with us before but if
not we do do it throughout their
duration of them Dan our protocol
you know we've got more questions next
one please tell us how you make soft
jackets for the rats about the the
sweaters and socks so we took longer so
I think they were for kids but they were
like knee-high socks so they were longer
than a normal shock but not as long as
like a knee-high socks for adults and
made sure that the end that way we also
got the cute little hearts and stripes
and things so we took a sock and we cut
off the toe ends of it and then like
kind of put a rat next we're planning on
using with that and guess where we would
need to put the holes for the legs we a
couple times we had to modify this a
little bit but had the rat go in and it
was the long enough to cover their tail
and still be comfortable for them and we
noticed that it only takes a couple
minutes to make them actually I would
definitely test drive different types of
socks depending on the size of your ass
and see how that works but it does tend
to not only make them easier to handle
for people who are afraid but it seemed
as well thank you for that answer
our next question asks how did you mark
how do you mark individual guinea pigs
for their three technique limit per week
we have since we have such few guinea
pigs we only have those eight guinea
pigs that I mentioned and guinea pig
labs there's not too many of them on
campus so usually right in our inning
log the name of the guinea pig what
technique I don't think you've ever done
you've ever had the opportunity to do
more than three techniques on a guinea
pig at one time but the guinea pig log
is a lot easy to read because it's veins
and it's only for eight animals so and
all different colors in our training
core and now I think I had a picture of
two of I know guinea pigs that was a
fairly rare we do have different colors
so they're a lot easier to tell apart
than our mouse populations so we do use
other names in the training
for that thank you
next question what age and weights range
do you target with mice and rats before
you start using the animals for training
classes we don't have a specific weight
and age range that we use we do make
sure all of the animals obviously are
weaned unless we get a special request
we have a lot of different things in our
protocol and so if somebody is a neonate
specifically pop for in inter pares
neoneun a pup for a mouse we usually get
those specially transferred but we can't
use those for those situations but for a
normal colony we usually make sure
they're obviously at least tell me what
we have a 21 day marker for being named
but usually beyond that there I'd say
about three months old for the mice and
similar for the rats as well before
they're really being used and around I'd
say 25 grams
thank you for your answer Kelly our next
question asks how do you address
compassion fatigue with staff and
researchers and do you address it that's
actually one of my pet projects outside
this presentation but I am running a
peer-to-peer support for compassionate
snake through the University of Michigan
unit for laboratory animal medicine and
this will soon I just started this about
six months ago or so but we started with
partnering with our counselor program
the University of Michigan we found a
few counselors I think we have two that
say they are fully comfortable talking
about animal research and the effects it
can have without being overly negative
or impacted by what we say so we offer
that to do to our technicians or maybe
having especially with compassion
fatigue but other than that once a month
I group being affected by compassionate
you can come by and share their stories
again it's peer-run so I kind of
encourage we're trying to facilitate the
discussion instead of just leaving it
and people can share their experiences
we go around campus to make sure I can
get everyone at some point and we're
also doing we're looking at creating a
memorial event so an annual memorial
event generally for animals in research
and we're actually also planning on
making a small memorial garden nothing
too obvious just a small garden with a
bench that we can think about the
animals we might have a small statue
we've had people put for a while we had
a traveling memory board where people
could put anonymous memories they had of
the animals it was acknowledged by other
staff members so that's one of our main
topics in the past year that we're
really working on for our technicians
the capacity support group I really
recommend sometimes I have only a few
people show up and the last one I had
over twenty and some management's have
showed up as well
I will say I'm thinking of creating two
groups for the different hierarchies of
our staff just so people feel fully
comfortable
I actually sharing how they're feeling
because sometimes little daunting if
your boss is there but so far I've had
no issues thank you
our next question asks the sitting class
how often how long are they who does
them and are they assigned as scheduled
this is a more kind of casual part of
our program we do it I try to do it at
least a few times with our animals so
the trainer will grab them from our
colony use them on the current in a
different location so our current has
two shelves so use this second shelf
with the animals that haven't been used
yet I'm usually sitting next Lily to be
on the cart where all the other animals
are or a lot of times I'll have the rats
next to me it's a little easier to fit
the caging that way and next to where
I'm giving the lecture but there's no
really set schedule we just try to do it
a few times until they until the animals
seem a little calmer or they've been in
our colony for a few weeks but we make
sure the trading stand for the ones to
do this and don't really documented well
we will right sometimes just handling if
we were handling them for acclimation
training afterwards once we bring them
in their room but that's just something
that I've noticed a specific impact on
our rat colony and since it is a smaller
colony and they are named so it's a
little easy to keep track of oh it looks
like some was really getting acclimated
to the room but yeah that one's still
kind of a little bit more subjective
Thank You Kaylee our next question asks
is there a maximum number of procedures
your training animals can undertake or
is it all time-based whatever takes
place within a year it goes on to say
I'm wondering primarily about the more
invasive procedures such as tail vein
injections staff earnest sampling
submandibular its sampling retro orbital
injections etc well I will say for
anything invasive such as surgery we
normally don't recover our animals from
our surgery classes so they only go
through actual invasive surgeries like a
laparotomy once for the tail vein and
the cement EPO leaves and things like
that we do mark their tails differently
with a red marker so we know that they
were and we and with those animals we
are very particular about trying to
rotate them a little bit with a little
bit of wider gap they are definitely not
used for even handling for that week
period but they are given the week and
the three techniques for tail vein for
example do count the tail poke so if
they tell they attacked us and we're
successful that counts as one technique
but we and for each session four if you
were bleeding from a tail vein we do
only allow once per session for actual
successful blood from the animal before
the animal is given that week vacation
all right our next question asks could
you tell me that if you view the
simplest ways to restrain rats for blood
collection oh well it just depend on
what type what site that you're getting
in the blood from for the animals we do
have tail vein restrainer that we get
entry scientific that we use if we're
getting tail vein doing Tayla injections
are very simply hold the N will allow
you to pull the tail and then have a
proper angle for those but other than
that I have I do know some people that
will use towels instead of the shoe
covers that we showed we generally just
kind of use our hands depending on the
size of the rats who restrain them but
again I think Braintree scientific does
have some really good holders for it
like for example tail vein for things
like anything else that you would need
we do just use our hands a lot of the
times I notice rats are a little calmer
than mice so we have had too many issues
or straining them we've also used
dekappa cones the plastic cones that
have and we cut a hole at the end if
they don't really have them that can
restrain them and like a plastic bag
like thing but they still have a no so
we had some success with those as well
you have to make sure they're sterile
for that answer next question how many
techniques maximum techniques do you
perform on your rats for the rats they
still everything in our colony has the
three techniques and then a week break
rule and again it's the same thing if
we're doing surgeries unless it's a spay
neuter surgery we don't normally recover
our animals so if they're in surgery
that's their final procedure we don't
usually do those until the animals need
the colony for whatever reason but they
are still following the three technique
and that does count attempts at gavage
attempts at tail vein things like that
anything that was stressful in an
attempt to technique how does it
Thank You Kelly next question I want to
ask if there are any differences between
conventional and transgenic animal
enrichments for our colony there's not
we do damage from the same for all of
our animals we don't have really any
immunocompromised issues to worry about
if there is in our general population
any changes in enrichment because of
transgenic transgenic animals it has to
be in the protocol of the lab I've never
really heard of the need for much
different enrichment I will say all of
our food products are besides the fruit
and veggies for the guinea pigs and
rabbits are sterile and packaged from
places like bioserve or things like that
so we make sure they come in to the
colony very clean but we don't really
have much different enrichment types for
anything animals in the training corps
they kind of run the gamut on a database
thank you next question is hands-on
training required at your facility for
research staff and you complete
competency assessments for your staff
after training that's a great question
yes so they first performed online
modules and then they have to have
hands-on training with us there are
several classes there's an animal room
procedures class where they learn how to
use our flow hood and how to do proper
micro isolator technique to make sure
animals stay yes or a specific pathogen
free and they also have to if they're
working with the mice go through our
in-person rat and mouse class where they
have to demonstrate three times that
they can properly restrain the animals
also if they're going to be doing
injections that we allow them to
practice injections with us there as
well so they do have to pass some online
modules and the trainer has to sign off
on them passing the hands-on
and I will say there has been a couple
times and we couldn't have somebody
because we weren't comfortable with them
working animals and they'll come back
most of the time we have open labs will
because well we're a lab staff can ask
for specific training in for example or
gavage and we'll just get out animals
and all the supplies have a trainer
there and teach them hands-on yes they
do have to prove competency and
restraints for the rats and ice before
they're allowed on their protocol thank
you for your answer Kaylee our next
question asks are your rat condos IBC I
apologize not quite I feel like I know
what that means it's on the tip of my
time not quite sure what that means the
hummer made from Allentown caging have
been safety tested things like that and
that
okay great um thank you our next
question asks can you give me more ideas
for mice enrichment do you just use
commercially bought items oh that's a
great question it's been one of our main
questions we'll even implementing all of
these new enrichment devices and things
what is really great for a mouse what we
found is above all else mice prefer to
nest giving you any other option the
most enriching thing you can give for
them is nesting material I personally
have found the best enrichment tape for
them is giving them an estimate or a
cotton square and enviro dry or that
crudely brown paper they get to weave a
nest and really create that
thermodynamic environment inside the
nest to keep them really warm I and keep
them hidden as well they usually make it
right in front where our husband is
trying to help check them other than
that we do use like paper towel tubes
and toilet paper tubes we had a
veterinary resident here that sent off
the glue from those to a lab to assess
for toxicity and safety and they came
back as safe to use for rodents so we
autoclave those and we offer those as
little Hut's or two huts for our mice as
well and we offer these shelters we
offer paper bags but mostly they really
like those toilet paper tubes and again
nesting used to leave so you can use
toilet paper and I would definitely
autoclave it and some of that crinkle
bedding I know there's these enviro
packs that they have the crinkle bedding
material inside a cotton like bag and
that's both of those very well but I
really think nesting is the number one
Richmond for mice
okay we have two more questions for the
day the this one asks do you find that
rats like being in the socks
does it not stress them stress them by
than being put into the socks and is
this good welfare putting them in the
socks to help humans not being so scared
of the rats we actually find found that
they like them I had again we don't do
this too often this is an extreme case
of somebody being very phobic of their
rats but we have known that they
actually tend to crawl in themselves
once they know what we're doing but even
the first time I will just put them in
there usually rats before do this are
acclimated to us is so their hand
handler acclimated and they don't
struggle or they don't try to get out
right so they just kind of lay down
usually they fall asleep in them so we
haven't seen any outward signs of stress
so again it's not done very often but
when it is they don't seem very stressed
out by it at all in fact they'll kind of
crawl in it and it's kind of like the
shoe cover somehow to get them out
but I will say our animals our hand team
before we do this so we don't do this
with animals at our hands thank you
our last question of the day asks how
tool motor rap for oral or other kind of
injections after surgery in their dorsal
region do you do it on the back if we
have to do like oral gavage that way
usually will hold the rats under their
front arms and hold them up like that
for or gavage in a tight restraint in
the hand I don't know if you have a a
suture sutured incision there you just
have to be careful of where you place
your hand but that's the most effective
way I found if you put your
and under their arms and kind of hold
them straight like that
to get that really straight access point
like a garage or some sort of so I and
this is actually another great point
that we use for our shoe cover is
strange if you have an area of the rat
that you can't put pressure on this kind
of gives you a bit more leeway on where
you put your hand because the shoe
covers already kind of restraining them
a little bit so you don't have to have
such a tight restrict with your hands so
I would definitely look into different
restraint devices in general again I
know there are a few companies I know
kind of thing braintree scientific as
long as we use a lot they have two
first-rate devices so it might be worth
it to look into something like if there
are no more questions today I would like
to once again thank senior training
specialist Kaylee Bennett for her
presentation Kaylee do you have any
final and closing comments no I'd like
to thank everybody for tuning in I hope
it was informative and that you took
something from it from our little colony
that can help you out and I always like
to stress that animal welfare is
obviously our number one concern and
really displaying that for our lab staff
is I think is a vital importance the
better we can take care of the animals
but better our science and our
researchers so I always keep that in
mind when you're working
I'd like to thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions we would like to
thank laberd's for today's educational
webcast this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through July 2017 lab routes
will alert you via email when it is
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with colleagues who may
have missed today's live events this is
Christina from lab rats comm we'll see
you here next time goodbye